we have clout in the world we can get  things done in the world think of what  some of our people are doing right now  we've got nurses in West Africa helping  to deal with Ebola we've got some of  those brave and professional Armed  Services anywhere in the world and  tonight's a good moment to say thank you  to them for all they do we're a nation  of great inventors not from the West I  think it's good to say I'm worried that  yesterday thank you very much the lady  makes an important point which is there  are people who come out of our armed  services who do have difficulties and  that's why we should be putting money  into the Armed Forces charities that  help homeless people and people also  with mental health problems when they  come out of our armed services you very  much Walton let's return to the